I've been building stuff since I could
walk
if I could get my hands on it I take it
apart and if I had an idea I try to
build it when someone says something's
impossible I can figure out the way to
make it possible this all started with a
visit to Tanzania there was this problem
with medical supplies it's not that
people don't have access to the doctors
it's the doctors don't have it medical
supplies on hand to treat them in most
of these developing countries you have
your capitals and then there's a handful
of paved roads to go out to the next
cities from there out the countryside
it's all dirt roads and most these
countries have nine ten months of rainy
season every year just results in trucks
literally stuck in the mud and supply
chains that can't get these medical
products out to the doctors who need
them
like every doctor I met was nearly in
tears over this issue that was the
beginning of this mission was to solve
that problem in a really magical way and
you can't do it with motorcycles or
trucks but you can do it with a simple
drum it took us months to build a
prototype and on the very first flight
of that one and only prototype we had it
flew and crashed that was a big setback
there was a lot of sort of regrouping
and soul-searching eventually be rallied
and learned from
figure out how to do things much better
one
we're delivering blood in Rwanda doctors
to children who are suffering from
malaria or mothers and have postpartum
hemorrhaging it's so simple if you have
the blood and it's so deadly if you
don't we get an order from a doctor by
text we put it into the zip and then
essentially you're firing it it will fly
automatically out to the site we'll send
a text message to your packages about to
arrive
[Music]
drop the package from the air and then
fly back
to provide a much more reliable a much
faster source for that blood is really
critical every day there's lives that
could be saved
[Music]
[Applause]
and be able to part of helping is really
an honor
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]